[Musique]
franck ferrand bonjour bonjour merci
d'être ici pour un vip qui vous est
consacré vous êtes non pas sur le
plateau de tv 60 18 mai au coeur du
théâtre motos anciennes sommes dans le
foyer pour une émission spéciale
vous êtes ici pour une raison bien
particulière à ce que vous pouvez nous
raconter votre la raison de votre venue
je suis très heureux d'être au théâtre
montansier pour tout vous dire c'est une
maison merveilleuse c'est une des plus
belles salles de théâtre de france
incontestablement et on la doit à la
célèbre montansier ce personnage haut en
couleur truculent dont j'ai souvent eu
l'occasion de raconter l'histoire on
pourrait d'ailleurs on aurait pu
imaginer le faire et oui le faire cet
après midi je changer de sujet là on en
parlait de la grande histoire de
versailles mais pas du château de
versailles de la ville de versailles
ce théâtre il a été inauguré en 1778 il
a connu toutes sortes de choses
extraordinaires est une grande maison et
je pense que c'est le seul théâtre de
france où vous êtes dans une loge qui
s'appelle sarah bernhardt une loge avec
des petits bonnets intérieur comme il se
doit à versailles 9 banques et quand
vous regarder par la fenêtre vous avez
depuis votre loge le bassin de neptune
et comme c'est l'heure des grandes zones
en plus on profite du spectacle
j'avoue que ça c'est pas mal mais je me
plaire mais vous êtes un grand amoureux
de versailles à un grand ami aussi fait
partie de l'académie de versailles des
de la société des amis de versailles
enfin bref vous avez une sorte de
passion on peut dire depuis 35 ans et
vous y avez vécu d'ailleurs week-end à
versailles par passion il faut lire
c'est à dire que en l'an 2000 je
commençais à envisager d'écrire sur
versailles
énormément de choses que j'avais à dire
que levet accumulées depuis des années
des années comme une documentation
phénoménal j'étais devenu l'ami des
conservateurs du château j'avais
beaucoup de d'ouverture dans certains
fonds d'archivés bref il fallait que
j'écrive et je me suis dit que le mieux
ce serait de le faire ici donc j'ai
quitté mon appartement parisien à
l'époque pour venir m'installer ici
pendant trois ans et satiriste jusqu'à
la fin de 2003 puis après à cause de la
radio ce n'était plus possible faire
l'aller retour entre paris et versailles
deux parfois trois fois par jour ça
devenait complètement dément donc j'ai
décidé d'aller me réinstaller à paris
mais c'était la mort dans l'âme
c'était un arrachement de quitter cette
ville dont vous êtes heureux de revenir
c'est très heureuse mais juste en
dessous mais je sais vous avez écrit
donc à ce moment là ils ont sauvé
versailles rééditer en 2012 la faille
après les rois et xavier de rangement
qui connaissait cette bibliographie
parker c'est vrai oui je précise qu'on
n'avait pas de prompteur
donc ça a été écrit à versailles après
où vous a demandé comme on l'a dit on
l'a pas encore dit le dictionnaire
hameau de versailles entre les effets
d'une biographie pour perrin d'un des
grands conservateur du château de
versailles en oui mais parce qu'ils lui
gérald van berchem
vdk comme l'appelaient ses confrères
dans le monde de la conservation du
patrimoine
vdk qui a régné il n'y a pas d'autre mot
sur le château pendant 27 ans avant de
tirer de façon un peu forcé sa révérence
en 1981 et donc j'avais écrit son
j'avais écrit sa biographie ça s'appelle
un gentilhomme averse a aimé vallat ont
pu effectivement kehl et valdez if we le
battery systems en tout premier texte
qui est un roman historique ce sont des
mémoires apocryphe de madame de
pompadour et ça je les écris
effectivement à la demande de flammarion
c'est mon premier vrai livre d'une
certaine façon le bal des ifs et ça se
passe aussi à versailles bref tu es
m'amène ici et tout me ramène toujours
mais ça c'est pour notre plus grand
plaisir
alors on va parler de l'actualité
l'actualité c'est ce livre on perd on
raconte et qui est en fait comment dire
ce sont plusieurs chroniques qui sont là
sont désertiques d'historia je suis
monsieur collaborateur privilégié
d'historia puisque j'ai la chance qu
historia mais mis un petit peu comment
dire
je suis un peu l'incarnation en ce
moment du titre après tentées tant de
très grands auteurs ou d'imaginer
historia c'est aussi bien gosselin le
nôtre et madelin que bien sûr bien où
frédérick masson que des auteurs plus
connu plus récents comme philippe
erlanger andré castelot ouanna de cours
à l'assuré donc se retrouver là pour moi
ça a été un grand moment c'est très
important de travailler avec historia et
la semaine l'ensemble de mes
contributions au magazine qui viennent
la salle vallier voilà il ya vingt-deux
histoire il y en a d'ailleurs trois qui
nous concerne versailles qui précède
versailles directement vous avez choisi
trois moments clefs qui concerne donc
louis xiv le 15 ou 16
vous me disiez trois moments un peu
sombre un plomb et je n'ai pas fait
exprès mais il se trouve que quand on
les réunit on peut dire qu'effectivement
il s'agit de la grande maladie qui va
porter louis xiv jusqu'au au bord du
précipice il a failli véritablement dans
les barreaux de la bataille des dunes
d'absolution
oui il était tout jeune il avait 20 ans
c'était le moment d amour avec avec la
belle marie mancini etc
c'est d'ailleurs à l'occasion de cette
maladie et de sa convalescence qui l'a
découvert le grand amour que lui vouait
mari il y as pour ce qui est louis 15 la
relation terrible de son attentat de la
cantate d'amiens en janvier 1757
c'est un épisode relativement oublié
aujourd'hui de l'histoire de france mais
qui à l'époque une amertume au sénat
mais surtout il a découvert finalement
que qu'il était presque à vide il faut
savoir qu'ils n'étaient oui vous êtes
bonne source
vous êtes vous lisez les bons livres
c'est voilà ce n'est pas beaucoup mais
gimont mais en fait on peut se demander
effectivement si saint louis 15 avait
une pleine conscience de l'impopularité
qui pouvait être la sienne dans le
peuple
avant cette affaire d'attentât il savait
que les parlements lui en voulait il
était à couteaux tirés avec la
magistrature française mais il ne savait
pas sûrement qu'une qu'une partie de la
population le considérer comme une sorte
de tyrans effroyable jusqu'à allait
attenter à sa vie même si en fait al
khalifa et pc mais bon ça a été quand
même un événement terrible et puis pour
ce qui est de pour ce qui est de louis
saez on parle de cette fuite à varennes
qui peut-être alors là c'est bien joué
de malchance mais un point hallucinant
oui malchance et puis en même temps on a
presque l'impression qu'il ne faisait
rien pour que ça marche
tous les six ans pour conduire à l'échec
cette cette fuite éperdue il semblerait
qu'au fond de lui le roi n'est pas eu
tellement envie qu'elle réussisse et ça
il l'a prouvé pas tellement cette
attitude si ça se trouve peut-être voilà
bon saurai jamais alors revenons à
l'actualité radio classique qui voit
toute nouvelle maison dans laquelle vous
êtes très bien génial vous y être
épanoui très épanouie 16 voix vous y
êtes à 9 heures le matin ou à 14 heures
exactement voilà alors j'y suis à 9
heures le matin et l'émission est
rediffusée légèrement
gonfler légèrement étoffé à 14 heures
mais c'est la même émission ont
néanmoins d'accord et à partir de 14h30
elle est podcastable la wii voilà donc
radio classique
mais écoutez sont toujours vos amours
sur l'histoire évidemment vous avez
choisi cinq thèmes car vous allez
aujourd'hui au théâtre montansier
enregistré cinq émissions publiques sur
la scène voilà nous enregistrons toute
une semaine spéciale c'est la première
fois que nous faisons cela sur radio
classique
extra parce qu'on est dans le cadre du
mois molière pas mal comme l'a75 très
mal vous inaugurez quelque part le mois
molière et ses émissions on pourra les
écouter du 10 au 14 juin exactement
toute la semaine lundi mardi à tous les
jours habituels de la semaine donc nous
allons commencer par un sujet j'allais
dire d'actualité en tout cas de
résonance mémorielle puisqu'il s'agit de
la paix de 1919 et ce traité de
versailles le fameux traité de
versailles mais on va raconter les
circonstances de la signature de ce
traité
et puis ensuite ce sera le grand
déroulement de l'histoire versailles est
d'une certaine manière avec la création
de la ville par louis xiv
donc ça c'est la deuxième émission la
deuxième sur scène elle a redit mardi à
dakar le mercredi 12 nous évoquerons le
départ de la course avait serré ça ait
déserté vers travailler la pâte et
manawi versailles a été construit
constitué pour nourrir la cour si je
puis dire tous les toute cette
population était constitué il y avait
des traiteurs il y avait des tailleurs
enfin y avait tous les gens avec la
société surtout en déclarant une petite
partie avec le roi et puis une immense
partie avait un lien avec tous ces
grands seigneurs et ces grandes dames
qui vivaient là qu'ils dépensaient sans
compter c'était formidable
la prospérité de versailles était
phénoménale pendant un siècle quand même
et puis d'un seul coup et ça c'est quand
même un cas unique c'est incroyable
le 6 octobre 1789 la foule des émeutiers
ont dit les parisiennes enfin y avait
aussi pas mal de parisiens
la foule arrive pour venir chercher le
boulanger la boulangère un petit mitron
on ramène donc louis saez marie
antoinette le dauphin et plus d'une
façon plus générale la famille royale la
cour en haleine tout le monde à paris et
comment va survivre
donc forcément ça c'est l'émission du
versus fait ça c'est toute une
c'est là que les maires notamment les
maires de versailles ont joué un rôle
important on va voir ça et puis le jeudi
alors je sais plus quel jour on sera le
jeudi on sera le 13 un jeudi 13 ça tombe
bien à une un quantième près on aurait
pu tomber sur un vendredi 13 mai non le
jeudi 13
on va évoquer un moment magnifique et
passionnant et en même temps très dures
de l'histoire versaillaise c'est le
moment de l'invasion prussienne
l'installation de tout le gouvernement
prussiens la cour de prusse ici à
versailles donc versailles après avoir
été capitale de la france pendant enfin
capital symbolique appareil est toujours
est-il qu'à pita en fait mais après
avoir dominé on va dire la france et
l'europe pendant si longtemps redevient
d'une certaine manière
de fait capital de la prusse 7e
concrètement pardon alors bel empereur
enfin celui qui était au départ le le
roi guillaume qui va devenir l'empereur
guillaume premier se trouve à la
préfecture qui vient juste d'être
construite là d'un faux nez
c'est là que lui s'est installé en tout
cas bismarck était rue de provence dans
un hôtel particulier qui s'appelle
l'hôtel de gcc
bref tout le monde s'est installé là pas
au château même mais alors je vous coupe
excusez moi alors versailles et est
toujours désert ou entre temps ça
s'était repris bien retient les peuples
est alors là voilà vous imaginez la
calamité des calamités cette occupation
prussienne et que tous ces généraux ces
chefs d'armée qui s'installe un peu
partout dans les appartements 20 et puis
à peine les prussiens parti en mars 1871
que le gouvernement provisoire le
gouvernement issu des urnes de février
71 revient de bordeaux pour s'installer
à paris sous la présidence d'adolphe
thiers et que c'est l'insurrection
parisienne ce qu'on va appeler la
commune de paris et allez ça recommence
et cette fois ce n'est pas une invasion
étrangère si je puis dire c'est une
invasion parisienne cette fois ce sont
tous les ministères toutes les
administrations tous les corps
constitués tout le corps diplomatique
qui viennent s'installer ici à
versailles de nouveau et ça va durer
longtemps
parce que si le président de la
république mcmahon or ce oui lui leur
parti à paris où il partit à paris à
l'elysée dès 1874 mais les autres ils
vont rester là il me restait à
versailles notamment notamment le
parlement jeudi le parlement parce qu'à
partir de 75 ya deux chambres il ya un
conseil de la république et une
assemblée non ça c'est sous l'impulsion
de ce volet chambre des députés et un
sénat et cette chambre des députés ce
sénat siège ici à versailles le sénat
dans l'ancienne opéra royal et la
chambre des députés dans le nouvel
hémicycle qu'on va construire exprès qui
aujourd'hui est encore les cessions les
unes du congrès oui très bien et en la
petite dernière chanson mais on va y
travailler alors on va y travailler pour
vous vous avez trouvé l'inspiration à
versailles c'est la grand voile à tous
c'est on aurait plus vite fait je vais
parler de proust je vais parler de
banville je vais citer albert samain
grands airs urbanité des façons ancienne
on va évoquer ces poètes ses auteurs et
ses ordres et chénier bien sûr on va
parler de ses auteurs de théâtre aussi
et de cinéma pensez à sacha guitry et à
l'extraordinaire à faire de si
versailles m'était conté aller jusqu'à
une période finalement intéressante oui
on va parler quasiment jusqu'aujourd'hui
le site et julien gracq qui dit qu'il ya
avait un versa et le pouvoir des flaques
de ciel dit il ça signifie quoi bon
écoutez génial écoutez bonne émission a
grandi si c'est bono émission on veut
des droits d émission tout à fait on a
de vous retrouver sur radio classique on
vous écoutera avec ferveur et plaisir et
dites moi le prochain livre
alors sache année est encouragée en
train de travailler
je veux pas trop en dire plus c'est un
ce sont des mémoires apocryphe comme
était mon tout premier livre le bal des
ifs
je ne vous dis pas de qui j'écris les
mémoires mais ça nous permettra de
parler pour l'enseignement est signé
avec lincei oui un lien
reportage entier merci franck ferrand je
me réjouis à très bientôt bonne émission
merci au revoir franck
[Musique]